foreign
yeah this is not a very useful way to
prevent
anything from getting covered but it is
a useful way of signaling something you
pick you picked these up at the
conference at the society for
integrative comparative biology
conference is that right I did I did
yeah well so
I mean uh but you also picked this up
which is awesome conference program yes
they gave that to me yeah and I have
I've begun reading it and I have some
things to share from it it's actually
super awesome in a lot of ways yes
and they're not so awesome in some ways
so let me just say oh wait the pride
masks the The Pride masks have attracted
the cat who has just changed things on
my computer by walking he is nothing if
not proud
um so let me just say I was in Austin of
course for for The Joe Rogan Experience
and
my hotel turned out to be the epicenter
of this conference which I did not know
was going to be there and it just sort
of emerged around me and I was you know
riding the elevators with these people
um so this was the society for
integrative and comparative biology
which you know that's not a conference I
ever attended a number of really
interesting talks but there's also the
sexual diversity and variation symposium
which I suspect it was those people who
were handing out These Guys these Pride
masks
it doesn't did include some talks that
appear to be actual science
um but it's mostly a smorgasbord of
self-indulgent confusion and was
co-organized by a graduate student
who will no doubt go far given that he's
playing by all the current ideological
roles and Fashions but his Twitter
profile and I'm not going to share
details or specifics of exactly who he
is or what his institution is so I'm
I've taken out the identifying features
here
um Twitter profile reads without the
identifying features
queer trans evolutionary biologist
aspiring plant hashtag scicom hashtag
cycom drag King relentlessly Earnest
they them
this is one of the co-organizers of one
of the symposia at one of the biggest
biology conferences going on
at all and happens to be going on right
now some of the talk titles organized by
this they them queer trans evolutionary
biologist as firing plant person are
linnaean Libertines
the queer possibilities of plants
and and this one appears to be from the
lab of someone who should know better
but the talk is fluidity and inconstancy
Australian bush tomatoes solanum as an
Exemplar of non-normative sex expression
in plants and across life non-normative
sex expression implants normative
normative in tomatoes
well if you were going to have something
non-normative I mean Australian bush
tomatoes right right sure pretty
non-normative yeah
as far as plants go in the direction of
non-normativity I would imagine that
tomatoes and especially the Australian
bush variety would be at the top of the
list it was the low-hanging fruit
[Music]
that was pretty well done actually yeah
um
but all right so this this does
seriously people I mean come on this
does get to the the central question
though is my my claim is if you have I
don't know how many people were at this
conference it was a big conference it's
a big conference if you have all of
these people actively involved in
academic biology
studiously not making eye contact with
the fact that there are supposed a
symposia that make no sense going on at
the conference where they are abiding by
mandates that make little sense at the
conference where they are the field
doesn't exist because the basic the idea
is
the whole point of science is that
you're supposed to follow the evidence
using the high the the hypothetical
deductive method of science to figure
out what is actually true and that is
the North Star to the extent that a
field is going to kowtow to fiction
right then it's not a scientific field
and it doesn't matter that it may
occasionally do something scientific
because the point is it has signed up
for a value system in which something
else apparently has priority and you
know I mean I I don't know anything
about this person who organized the
Symposium but
you can certainly imagine knowing what
we saw in Academia as you say a person
is likely to go far why because nobody's
going to be in a position to say
actually that work wasn't good enough
that work didn't mean anything once more
it wasn't scientific right because if
you did say that to somebody who claimed
to be
trans then the point is oh well you're
discriminating against me because I'm
trans check and mate check and mate and
also I mean he
he's doing it very effectively now
because just like publisher Parish used
to be the rule of law in Academia and it
sort of expanded to well also you're
expected to do Outreach and you're
supposed to have all of these different
kinds of experiences where and you
engage with with the broader community
and so it's not just publishing
peer-reviewed academic papers you know
on which we have talked a lot about the
problems there
um but that you know that had been sort
of the gold standard
this person has now organized a
symposium at one of the largest
biological conferences and previously
gave a talk at another given invited
talk at another conference and those two
things on a CV applying from applying
out of grad school for a postdoc
that's huge most people don't have that
most most crowd students don't have that
so you know and yet the topics of both
the talk which they're not going to
spend time on here and this Symposium at
this conference are not scientific
there's there's no science there as far
as I can tell
um and you know no I wasn't there and
they don't have the talks up yet they
are going to post the talks and I was
going to watch them but they're not up
yet
but it it gives the appearance it's like
it's it's it's it's potemkin science
it's potemkin Academia it's you know
this this facade and all you have to you
know the line on the CV is what
potential employers you know academic
employers will be looking for like oh
well look at you aren't you a go-getter
haven't you done a lot of good work like
well I did do work
it doesn't look like it was good no but
it's even it's even worse than that I'm
sure um well here's how it's worse
imagine that your core uh desire in life
was
trans activism yeah you know you know
it's a real pain in the ass if you're a
trans activist
evolutionary biology right so if you if
your core thing was to shut those
evolutionary biologists up right people
who understand that reef fish aren't the
invalidation of binary sex right
um You might go get yourself one of them
fancy phds in evolutionary biology and
you might wield it like a weapon so I'm
expecting that we're going to see this
emerge as you know and you know and you
can imagine unless the world gets over
the idea that as soon as you're trans
you're right
you know as soon as we get over that
idea we can skip this but until then
what this means is that as this person
is able to set up symposia and give
invited talks in order that people can
you know I don't know satisfy their cow
Towing obligations or whatever right
this person is going to gain power and
that power is going to be used for what
I call Ideal laundering right he's going
to launder wrong ideas into evolutionary
biology which is going to make it harder
and harder to do high quality
evolutionary biology because you know
are you going to cite it are you going
to ignore it what do you do right
um and I will point out I I think it's
Michelle Foucault
who essentially argued to Trojan Horse
fields to enter them and disrupt their
ability to do what they do maybe it was
Marcus but I think it was Foucault but
in any case it's somebody's idea that
the purpose of this stuff is actually
its activism and disruption and so you
know
wake up evolutionary biologists there's
one headed your way yeah right and you
know it's already inside the house right
the call is now coming from inside the
house and I will just say you know
this is not to say that trans people
shouldn't be able to do evolutionary
biology but if your purpose is to just
disrupt evolutionary biology with
nonsense stuff right I mean the fact is
if you land in evolutionary biology as a
trans person
what are the chances that you also land
on that as your topic
right in other words why are you not
studying chelation and the scales of a
you know fence lizards or something
right why are you studying that exact
thing and does that not suggest that
maybe you've landed there because
evolutionary biology is not your top
priority but something else is exactly
so I will I've told this story before
but
um the the line in the in the bio of the
person who co-organized the Symposium
queer slash trans evolutionary biologist
whenever I see something modifying
evolutionary biologist that isn't
that isn't like a
a narrowing of what kind of evolutionary
biologist you are yeah
um I think to
uh I know exactly what you're saying
yeah yeah you know the story I'm gonna
tell
um
I think to when I was trying to sell my
first book antipode
and it was about my research and life in
Madagascar and I had uh I had a good
agent and he was pitching it and this
was long before we ever lived um in
Portland or anywhere in the Pacific
Northwest but actually there was a small
press in Portland that showed that
showed the first interest and I ended up
getting it published by a major
publishing house but this small press
showed interest and they were offering
you know nice amount of money for a grad
student maybe he already made any money
at all at that point
um and they were super interested
because they said
um it's a story of feminist science
I said nope
nope can't can't go there won't go there
because that's not a thing
and they're like what do you mean it
feels you know okay so and there's
actually there's no mention of feminism
in the book but I said well you know as
a woman who goes alone these places you
know you must be a feminist and at that
point this would have been
late 90s early odds it's like you know I
actually do I did still think of myself
as a feminist at that point but um
that's separate from being a scientist
and you can't modify scientists with uh
feminist because the feminism is an
ideological position
and uh and if that is informing if that
is modifying linguistically scientist
then your science is suspect and your
science is flawed and you aren't holding
the scientific process as the thing that
is most important because if you're
doing science and you ask a question
that comes up with an answer that you
you come up with an answer that you
don't like you're not expecting you wish
weren't true
it's still the answer
and if you are informing your science
with some ideology which is likely to
have you push some answers and deep six
others then you're not really doing
science so same thing queer trans
evolutionary biologist like you can be
it was talking like no one can Define
queer so let's just put queer no no no
no
two things one it's not the story I
thought you're gonna tell but
the fact that queer shows up
without a meaning in this case right
right is in and of itself an indication
that something is up here right how is
it not redundant with trans
yeah but I mean like you could as you
already said like you can be trans and
you can be an evolutionary biologist but
putting them together oh validates the
scientist part totally agree but the
fact of putting queer and trans together
as a co-modifier right that sounds like
it's rather full of meaning what exactly
is that meaning yeah right so I once
yeah long ago tweeted uh
something like if the queue were removed
from lgbtq who exactly would be excluded
and got not a single useful answer
so saying well then what is this
community right I'm not saying there's
no Community but I'm saying why is there
an extra letter in there if not as some
kind of
um mechanism to do something other than
convey meaning yeah if there's no
meaning but the story I thought you were
going to tell
was when we were at Evergreen there was
a hire that was Advanced for a feminist
Economist and you and I both raised this
exact issue saying
yeah an economist is supposed to
describe how economics works and the
idea that you've put an ideological
modifier on it means that's not what
you're doing right you've effectively
advertised a filter so it's the same
same meaning when I when I argued
against that position because I think
both you and I were on sort of the
general hiring committee to decide at
that point so we both got supposedly had
some voice there but didn't make a
difference I believe I told the story
that I just told here then too because
it
it just it's it can't work that way and
everyone is buying the Press of for the
people who are claiming to be the most
the most damaged and and hurt by
societal strictures and we just we just
have to stop yeah we have to we have to
stop
yep
I'm an environmental mathematician
in fact I don't know okay
[Music]